Welcome back everyone this is my video all about
daredevil coming back to the mcu and daredevil
characters showing up in marvel marvel netflix
characters coming back we just got a report about
a bunch of other series where these characters
are going to be showing up so we'll break it
all down there's a bunch of easter eggs and
connections too in the storylines that they're
doing if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos this will be
happening on some of the disney plus series but
also some of the marvel movies that are coming up
in marvel phase 4. if you didn't see the news in
the past day there's a report going around some of
the larger websites circulating that daredevil
netflix characters are going to be showing up
way more than you thought that they were
last year you probably remember all the
reports about charlie cox's daredevil appearing
in spiderman no way home as matt murdock not as
daredevil but as lawyer matt murdock there's
been all kinds of speculation about what he's
actually doing during that movie people claim
that they saw him on set there's been all kinds
of speculation there's just a lot of ways that
you could explain matt murdock would be useful
inside of spider-man story given the plot that's
happening during spider-man no way home given all
the problems that he's got right now spider-man
really needs to find himself a solid lawyer
tom holland did say that they had a funny way
of addressing that whole storyline with mysterio
like it'll be a little bit funny but also serious
at the same time it won't all be mine for comedy
i've already done a couple videos about that so
i'll post those links down in the description
but recently the bigger report about all these
other big netflix marvel characters coming back
just details all the other projects where this is
going to be happening and how it's going to happen
in the next big character that it seems
like they're bringing back is vincent
d'onofrio's kingpin in a bigger way than i ever
expected so that's actually really good news
ever since the talk about bringing matt murdock's
daredevil back from the netflix series people have
wanted kingpin to come back he's just way too big
of a marvel character for you to not use him in
marvel phase 4. vincent d'onofrio is also recently
liking posts talking about him being in the
hawkeye series seemingly confirming those reports
i'm sure kevin feige was really happy to find out
about that it'll make a little more sense when i
explain where these characters are supposed to be
showing up the next big place they're supposed to
show up though is on the hawkeye series later this
year which takes place in and around the new york
city area because of kate bishop's origin story
kingpin is supposed to show up as part of
the mob storyline that runs through that
and apparently the people that were reporting
kingpin's casting in the hawkeye series were also
reporting that it was originally supposed to be
daredevil showing up on the hawkeye series which
would have been awesome but apparently there
was some scheduling conflict with charlie cox
and that's what led kevin feige to swap in
vincent d'onofrio's kingpin character which
is still awesome and that just on top of what's
happening with yelena belova in that black widow
post-credit scene teaser just setting up one of
the major story lines on hawkeye is yelana belova
versus hawkeye the whole idea is that yelena
bilova was given a contract to kill hawkeye
from val madame hydra the contestant whatever you
want to call her julie louis dreyfus character
that we saw in falcon and winter soldier
she's going around recruiting herself a very
thunderbolts looking team but whoever is pulling
her strings whoever val works for is the person
who wants hawkeye dead kingpin is also a master
of manipulating people into doing what he wants
but as far as i know the kingpin storyline on
hawkeye is not connected to the yelena belova
storyline on hawkeye but the sheer fact that he's
showing up on hawkeye just canonizes more of the
daredevil marvel netflix characters it's a little
bit of a star wars situation like if you remember
how star wars when it was bought by disney they
put a lot of the older material the books the
tie-ins into what they call the legends category
star wars legends but every once in a while dave
filoni john favreau like on the mandalorian will
sort of pluck characters from legends out and make
them cannon again like dave filoni recanonized
grand admiral thrawn where is your master
where is grand admiral thrawn so that's kind
of what kevin feige is doing with the marvel
netflix characters starting with daredevil
kingpin in reportedly jessica jones as well
but the reported plan for kingpin and daredevil
right now is that you have all those rumors about
daredevil showing up in spiderman no way home
it seems a little more concrete with kingpin
showing up in the hawkeye series but during the
hawkeye series they're establishing the echo
character from the comics and they're already
doing a spin-off series with her on disney plus
the report goes on to say that both kingpin and
the daredevil character would be bigger characters
inside the echo series whenever they do release
that there's a big connection between them in the
comics i'll explain in a second but also on top of
that daredevil has also been reported to show up
in the she-hulk episodes next year which is also
a new york city-based series like these other ones
jennifer walter she-hulk is a lawyer representing
superheroes mutants other weird marvel characters
daredevil is also a defense lawyer by day so you
can see the logic in using him on that series as
well there may be some other small cameos from
daredevil netflix characters like karen page
foggy nelson eventually maybe even jon bernthal's
punisher at some point but for right now these
are the four movies in disney plus series that we
know about that daredevil himself or matt murdock
or kingpin are showing up on i will explain what's
been said about potential for a kingpin spider-man
crossover later too because it already sounds like
we're getting some daredevil netflix crossover
with the spider-man characters but starting
in the hawkeye episodes later this year the
report is that marvel still plans on releasing
it in late november right after the miss marvel
episodes and both miss marvel and hawkeye will
have six episodes each just like loki and falcon
and winter soldier so that just means the episodes
will be a little bit longer about the same length
as loki episodes and the reason why kingpin is
connected to the hawkeye characters is because
of the kate bishop mob storyline so the villains
of hawkeye might wind up being the tracksuit mafia
clown we've already seen a little bit of footage
of them filming with those characters clown is
a mercenary working with the tracksuit mafia this
part of the map fraction hawkeye run that they're
using as the basis for the story so if you want
to read up on what's going to be happening during
the events of hawkeye the cape bishop origin story
just read that matt fraction run it's great madame
mask also might wind up being one of the villains
in the hawkeye series there was a version of madam
masks that they did way back on the agent
carter series but that was during the 1940s
when that was happening and it was a version
of whitney frost before she became madame mask
so i don't know if they're planning on connecting
that version of the character with a potential
madam mask in present day but in present day she's
connected to kate bishop's mother who's actually
being played by vera farmiga and because she's a
pretty big actress it sounds like her character
is going to be a bit bigger on the series as
well they might wind up combining a couple of
comic book characters too like they did in the
loki series with kang and he who remains marvel
does that a lot where they'll combine characters
backstories the kingpin connection is with kate
bishop's parents her father has deep connections
to the mob in new york city her mother too but her
father really isn't anyone all that special in the
grand scheme of things he's just someone who gets
tied up in a lot of really bad mob stuff and that
provides the basis for kate bishop's origin story
the mcu version of this will just be a little
bit different because of what happened during
avengers infinity war with the snap avengers end
game the blip and all the stuff that's happened
since the events of avengers end game the only
thing we know about the timeline of the hawkeye
series is that it's going to pick up after the
events of the black widow post-credits scene
which itself takes place a while after the events
of avengers end game like at least six months
after avengers end game because it seems like
yelena belova has been working for valve for
quite a while if it wasn't clear from the events
of the black widow movie it's implied that one of
the reasons why natasha black widow was so willing
to sacrifice herself during avengers end game
was not only because she was trying to save her
avengers family like sacrificing herself to get
the soul stone so that they could bring everyone
back but it's also implied that her russian family
from the black widow movie like yelena belova
was also snapped during avengers infinity war
so she was sacrificing herself to bring her
sister back so to speak given that it makes a
little more sense why she'd be so quick to throw
herself off the cliff when a lot of people were
like shouldn't hawkeye have actually died there it
sounds like where they're bringing the daredevil
and kingpin characters into the mcu during marvel
phase four they're just going to explain that the
events of the daredevil netflix episodes were
happening while marvel phase 1 phase 2 phase 3
were happening so you kind of get a loose sense
for what the timeline is so you have to imagine
that daredevil season 3 was ending just before the
events of avengers infinity war because they don't
address it at all during that and they haven't
explained anything about whether or not daredevil
kingpin or the other marvel netflix characters who
are coming back were snapped but they'll probably
explain that when they show up on hawkeye she-hulk
the echo series in the still rumored spider-man no
way home connection the whole connection between
the echo character daredevil and kingpin because
apparently they're all showing up during the echo
series is the kingpin hires echo to kill daredevil
by tricking her into believing the daredevil
was responsible for the death of her father in
ekko's powers are a little bit like taskmasters in
the comics not the version of taskmaster that we
saw in the mcu but comic book taskmaster echo has
photographic reflexes she can copy other people's
moves so she just copies daredevil's moves when
she's fighting him it sounds like when she shows
up during the hawkeye series she'll already be
a mercenary and they'll just cover her backstory
during the echo series just in terms of potential
kingpin spider-man crossovers in the mcu vincent
d'onofrio has long previously said he would love
to do a spider-man story but that was a couple of
years ago right after they canceled the daredevil
series and all the other marvel netflix series
long before kevin feige started bringing the
characters back in the mcu so anything is possible
but i don't think that kingpin would ever be the
main villain of a tom hall in spider-man movie but
he could always get a cameo in a future spider-man
movie i do think long term eventually there's a
solid chance they could do a new daredevil season
on disney plus like a daredevil solo season
without him just crossing over into other people's
series everyone let me know in the comments what
do you want them to do with daredevil and kingpin
in the future of the mcu now that they're bringing
the netflix characters back and because we just
had the loki series yes there is a connection
between kate bishop and kang the conqueror through
the young avengers but i still think it's going
to be a long time before they're ready to do
a young avengers disney plus series or a movie
but if we do see any easter eggs for those in the
episodes of course i'll point those out when i do
my videos for them marvel's what if series is
going to start really soon on disney plus i'll
be doing episode videos for that so just make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss anything
everyone click here for that brand new venom
let there be carnage trailer and to listen to
kevin feige explaining venom in the mcu and click
here for that loki season 2 teaser and deleted
scenes with kang thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!